non c'è veramente fatemi cagare in pace
per marca [ __ ] ok bella tutti ragazzi e
benvenuti a questo nuovo video sono fa
vj ed oggi siamo sud corset forest che
solo il nome vi fa cagare addosso da
perché i ragazzi ovviamente eravate
tutti tipo anno ma fa vi prego vai lì
non rosselli che da secoli che lo fa ok
siccome ragazzi non è abbastanza nuovo
ce ne sono ma mai in pochissimi l'ha
giocato sto coso o seriamente paura di
essere uno dei primi a scoprire o
seriamente paura che se uno dei primi a
scoprire la bellezza di quest'opera
d'arte ragazzi sarà veramente molto
tranquillo questo è sicuro veramente
ragazze neanche soffiarsi il naso
perfetto 13 agosto mi chiamarono al
telefono e mi diedero delle brutte
notizie mia madre ebbe un attacco di
cuore e quindi corsie da lei il cammino
incitavo lungo e quindi decisi di
tagliare passando attraverso un posto
desolato giustamente ragazze e quindi
non fui io ma come fa un cristiano a
leggere la divina commedia in quattro se
questa era 3 con lui che ragazzi siamo
partiti allora ho capito che questo
stava cercando di andare a trovare sua
madre ma sfortunatamente si è ritrovata
in mezzo alla merda ragazzi cose
normalissime cioè non vi capita mai di
tornare a casa da scuola è camminare per
un sentiero un po strano bellissimo
questa è la trama visto gioco fantastico
ma la cosa più [ __ ] di tutto e che c'e
l'ombra the void altri ragazzi sto gioco
è fatto col cryengine che un motore
grafico potentissimo tra i migliori
infatti cioè la grafica della madonna
per essere un indie non ho mai giocato
se mi paghi in testa ma quanti schiaffi
ci manca solo che pincio giangia è una
giornata di merda ci mancano solo i
piccioni che mi cagano in testa perché
le foglie mi seguono le foglie che
cadono mi fanno paura ragazzi noi
andiamo via di qui prima possibile e
devo allora siccome ci sono due strade
perfetto un cartello c'è un qualcosa per
capire dove andare a perfetto vado lì la
che c'è luce oggi surf a vijay vi
insegnerà come sopravvivere quando
andato a trovare vostra mamma perché vi
perdete nelle foreste e una cosa che
capita molto spesso quindi seguite
questo tutorial su come sopravvivere
nelle foreste a caso c'è una cosa che
capita
la mia ombra anni fa cagare addosso in
una maniera che non avete idea comunque
devo farti capire che cazzo devo fare
qui che ancora non ho capito c'è una
porta al match di dispiace centric aa
perfetto il letto c'è una casa di merda
progetto è perfetto c'è mica tanto
qualcuno ci ha caricato sopra una chiesa
nel forte può ancora non ho trovato
nulla devo capire che cazzo ci lo fa
allora quando non serve a niente che è
successo come t come ti perdona ti
prendo ma guardi ti denuncio giuro che
ti appena appena vede un avvocato
ragazzi non ci sono più le rocce di una
volta ora sono tutte scortesi che
tentano di caderti in testa la prima
occasione vera e bastarde che sono e c'è
un po di nebbia la cosa non mi attira
però io ci vado lo stesso perché sono
fuori di testa e non me ne frega un
cazzo quindi andiamoci la prima regola
ragazzi per sopravvivere in una foresta
sconosciuta e vai tuffarsi in un lago
che appare per caso come faccio io
perfetto e devo allora facciamo un paio
di bracciate a stile libero visto che
siamo in un'oasi veramente paradisiaca
mi sembra di essere a loro ai ragazzi
non mi sembra anche a voi
comunque se non con sesto posto ha
trovato otto ragazzi ho trovato una
dentiera una dentiera questa di mia
nonna gliela porto re grazie mille ho
trovato una dentiera che sarà di sicuro
utilissima devo sti piccioni del cazzo
ragazzi lo scopo visto gioco e trovare
trovare dentiere e la cosa un osso
perché se un braccio su un tavolo ma
voglio preso tra ragazzi ancora non ho
capito perché è uno che arriva e tenta
di fare amicizia viene respinto così
madonna mia che informa i ragazzi in che
mondo viviamo è diventata così
sostenibile che è caduto visto ti ho
visto un 3 fornovo brutto e inutile che
ti nascondi zio perché nascondino sono
un fenomeno ho già trovato stronzo di
merda è uscito battuto già preso inutile
che ti nascondi la gente che tenta di
competere a nascondino mi veramente mi
fa una pena perchè lo sanno che non
vinceranno mai c'è un altro osso intanto
non so perché io trovo ossa in giro a
caso c'è una cosa che non perché ci sono
sparse per terra ragazzi ancora locale
l'ho visto ho visto affanculo stavolta
ti piglia ragazzi dove che va a chi non
lo vede che sparisce a caso cioè noi non
lo vedo più vado avanti e non c'è più a
caso vabbè non importa andiamo di quei
ragazzi dico ci fa passare magari
abbastanza dentiere per passare di qua
speroni sii l'obiettivo principale tra
l'altro credo sia raccogliere le ossa
così almeno posso cos'è con la roma li
ho io non ho fatto un cazzo
avete visto tutti che non ho toccato
niente è stato lui ragazzi questo ciò
che ho sporto ma tanto vinco io non c'è
verso può tentare quanto vuole voi voi
ricordatevelo comunque che siamo tre a
zero per me io l'ho già visto tre volte
e lui continua a scappare che è successo
ragazzi questo è ufficialmente un posto
di merda però non è non ho ancora capito
fate mentone qua dentro prima che
succeda qualcosa ancora non sa che bella
foto c'è ma mi odia ma da quanto la
wagon e sulla razzisti posti fatemi
capire cos'è prendi la roccia con le
rocce macerone dove sto bastardo
tanto che adesso ti pigli adesso ti
fermi tutti cosa facciamo qui ci
nascondiamo in soffitta guarda che ti ho
già visto in tv
che la [ __ ] ok ok facciamo che siamo
3 a 1 te la do vinta stavolta ok a
prendiamo la roccia come allora non ti
nessuno ti ha visto stai tranquillo
adesso esco di qua adesso esco di qua
tranquillo oddio ma mi sembrava le ore
visto qualcuno ma di sicuro devo essermi
sbagliato di sicuro nessuno è salito in
soffitta mi sto sbagliando io quindi
usciamo di qua perfetto ho come la
sensazione che qualcuno ci stia
affermando ma non penso c'è un cesso
giunge veramente fatemi cagare in pace
va bè ragazzi abbiamo appurato che il
suo gioco non si può neanche cagare in
pace meno male che sei uscito prima
perché ti giuro avrei tirato fuori il
birillo avrei iniziato a pisciare quindi
meglio così io lo dico io a guarda per
sicurezza meglio così
ed è una cosa la posso prendere
ma [ __ ] c'è una torcia attaccata
al muro e non la prendi che già non si
vede una mazza
vabbè andiamo dico perché lui è l'unica
strada illuminata tra l'altro io vado di
qua perché non vedo altre strade e spero
di riuscire ad andare avanti senza
quindi salti fuori qualcosa lo sapevo
che il calcio successo ogni teatro
ragazzi ci sono sì black out che non
capisco che cosa è andare di qua ci si
può si può andare ma non è consigliabile
andare nell'acqua comunque io vado di
coca e grazie mille stato trovato una
roccia prima che cazzo mi serva una
roccia in un gioco così
[Musica]
brutto figlio di quotata ragazzi non
vale nascondersi nemmeno nell'acqua
virtuali e non la tigna the ok ok ok
perché ho perso gli occhiali nell'acqua
si può perdere ma gli occhiali nell'arco
in un momento così di merda ci siamo
ragazzi ci siamo nuovi in chianti lo fa
button passato sono passato mio dio devo
il telepass quindi a posto mi sta ancora
seguendo quel non posso neanche girarmi
per vedere se mi sta seguendo ancora qua
l'edizione posso vedere bene che mi
frase mi giro tipo non ok ma [ __ ]
tre passi in più mio dio non è che se
nella merda sei nella correzione è
sparito perché vedevo perde prima cioè
che mi avevano vomitato addosso cosa
allora ragazzi ci sia siamo usciti
miracolosamente da quella merda li fate
mica io vado dico perché è illuminato
cioè dove c'è luce io vado a caso c'è
tra l'altro non sono non sta neanche
caffè ma poi con il tizio come cazzo fai
essere ovunque c'è prima e da una parte
poi è ma che giornata di merda però ma
che cazzo va bene
non è possibile ha detto agli tim alice
si ok ok perfetto né una roccia mi stava
cadendo addosso
facciamo finta di niente non so neanche
che cazzo è successo ma me ne frego
perché ormai è successo già di tutto
vado avanti di qua ragazzino nomi non mi
spiegherò mai perché cazzola gente si
deve infilare le foreste dei nelle palle
non lo so ragazzi io non capisco perché
c'è un'altra c'è un'altra dentiera
perfetto ce n'è ma mi mancavano aveva
nostalgia ormai cos'è questo è il
perfetto il torace ci manca soltanto le
gambe a sto punto se magari non mi
crollasse ogni volta qualcosa in testa
sarei più contento ma non fa niente
tanto ormai è successo già di tutto è
una cosa
mi sono fatto malissimo ci siamo ragazzi
ci siamo il nuovo bilancio messo
mezz'ora ritornare quella che io lo dico
se ho capito bene devo cercare di
trovare una strada alternativa senza che
quel tizio un i salti addosso ragazzi ma
ditemi voi se io per non incontrare quel
tizio devo farmi ste cazzo le strade c'è
ma mio zio il tomtom mi sta dicendo di
tornare indietro da un'ora e mezza ma
non importa
ancora non ho capito scendi stronzo se
mi crolla la montagna [ __ ] scendi
scendi ragazzina ditemi se è normale che
devo fare ste cose io sì sì già fatta ce
l'ho fatto che calmi ragazzi carnage
dove siamo a secondo lei è perfetto mi
sono ritrovato siamo dove avevamo prima
qualcosa sia aperto perfetto spero non
sia il suo culo ragazzi dobbiamo tornare
credo le perché deve diventare verde a
caso perché ragazzi andiamo avanti
perché ancora non ho capito dove cazzo
siamo e perché devo tornare nel
passaggio di prima con la dove non mi
diceva vince se mi cade qualcosa in
testa io ammazzo qualcuno ragazzi io non
ho ancora capito solo vivo per miracolo
come incazzo fatto a schivare quel
tronco ragazzi non lo so non mi chiedete
come ho fatto non lo so ma l'ho vista
veramente brutta
comunque allora devo tornare nel
passaggio di prima
buongiorno vi presento sono famiglie
piacere
allora lei è molto molto triste mi fate
capire un attimo che cazzo ci fa un
orsacchiotto di peluche
in mezzo a un bosco o finalmente dopo
anni ho ritrovate un'altra cazzo di cosa
che non ho capito cos'è per che
lampeggia questa che cazzo ho trovato
cos'è allora che facciamo finta che sto
coso non lo debba prendere perché tanto
non mi pare che serva qualcosa quindi
andiamo avanti di qua speriamo di
trovare qualcosa che non sia sempre quel
demente vestito di nero che mi appare
ormai avanti non ce la faccio più i
ragazzi abbiate pazienza
devo trovare quel testo che cos'è dove
siamo cos'è e una ok ok calmi calmi che
questo mi piace di più toc toc permesso
sono fa vj fatemi entrare
fatemi entrare a chi quella fruttano non
sono morto morto si è sparito lo sa e
allora dillo che non sa che 8 bastardo è
sparito l'osso a kyoto perfetto allora a
porta non si apre quindi evidentemente
lasciamo perdere non si capisce più un
cazzo perché ci sono le luci che
lampeggiano dove cazzo siamo ragazzi
cioè il cuore che non me lo sento più mi
sta battendo talmente forte al cuore
legati mista mi posso aprire una band e
fare il batterista praticamente
succede rega che cazzo ok ok ciao luca
ti giuro sono al limite funziona può più
è una cosa pazzesca enuncia
con l'aiuto basta basta cosa sono sti
terremoti di merda una tenda di una
terra si sono qui solo che sono famiglia
ok ragazzi direi che forse concludere
qui questo primo episodio per il fatto
che come gioco indie a parte che
spettacolare ma il lunghissimo cioè
lunghissimo ma che cazzo ne so non
ancora finito comunque a comprimere
ragazzi nel prossimo episodio forti di
sapere ovviamente con un commento mi
piace se il video vi è piaciuto anche a
pagina di facebook e come ogni video
trovate nella descrizione a 0 0 che
rischi di scriveteli noi ci rivediamo
nel prossimo lido belle ragazze